this morning Dave Berry the legendary
humorist and Pulitzer Prize winner is
out with his first novel in 10 years
swamp story published by Simon Schuster
a part of Paramount Global it is a
rollicking look at fame fortune and
Florida but also a chance for Barry to
Russell with some of the pain in his
past to talk about all of it we met very
near his home in South Florida where
Miami meets the Everglades
Dave Barry's done plenty of book tours
but never one on an airboat you know
more cities would use airboats we could
get rid of a lot of these cars that are
causing so much environmental damage
yeah because this doesn't burn any gas
no it's it's quiet it's like an electric
car you can't even what the volume of
this watercraft is matched only by the
hidden gems that surround it alligator
Gator right there there's a gator oh
there she is
how did you see that I'm a journalist
Dave I have eyes
if they work this night one of us their
first instinct is going to start to
barrel roll and you definitely want to
stop them from doing that first instinct
you want to do is have somebody jump on
the back to prevent her from rolling
over so okay if she grabs you I'll jump
on her okay yeah all right thank you
you're at the point we have a plan now
[Music]
Barry did turn a couple guys acting
foolishly in Florida into a piece it
wouldn't be the first time it was
frequent fodder for him while working at
the Miami Herald where Barry wrote a
syndicated column for 22 years that won
him a Pulitzer Prize while he authored
dozens of books
Works served as inspiration for the mid
90s sitcom Dave's world starring Harry
Anderson yeah I'm rereading worst class
trip ever that's it's funny Barry's
latest swamp story tells the tale of a
ragtag group of Floridians searching for
a lost treasure Jesse Claude at the soft
dirt until she had uncovered a metal bar
roughly the same shape as a patio brick
but about half the size the gold you
talk about in the book there's long been
rumors that something like this actually
exists do you think it does I'm not
telling you yeah
I don't know there are there is uh one
pretty
well-founded story about a Confederate
Army payroll
shipment with gold they were being
chased by the Yankees and they hid the
gold somewhere in the Everglades there
are people who believe that so why not
for the most part swamp story is classic
Berry non-stop humor
but sunk inside is also a serious
undercurrent
including an alcoholic ex-newsman the
character you're talking about Phil is
the basically the closest to me my point
of view he's an older guys a newspaper
guy I just wanted his there to be some
like heart in the book and and that's
Phil he's he's got a a real problem and
I just wanted to talk about how how he
has to wrestle with that there's a
moment where his daughter confronts him
yeah that I I don't usually get
emotionally wrapped up when I'm writing
I'm just thinking about what the words
are but uh I was crying like a baby when
I wrote that that story that that part
of the story that scene
long ago when my dad was still drinking
my mom asked me to come and and talk to
him and I was his son you know it's my
20s he was my dad had always worshiped
and it was it didn't go well he was my
dad and he he wasn't ready to to you
know to deal with his his drinking so we
sort of managed to just put me off but I
was very much thinking about that when I
wrote that scene
that was a tough one to write
Barry's father did recover
but his mother died by Suicide
examples of the pain and joy that have
informed Barry's comedy I don't want to
write serious things because it usually
means something serious has happened I'd
rather be Mr joke guy and not you you
know worrying about what I'm feeling but
me making you laugh
nothing says laughter like getting up
close and personal with hungry
alligators this guy's teeth are a little
tricky and he's moving his head because
as if the boat ride didn't get as close
enough
our team arranged a second encounter
[Laughter]
I was told multiple times not to enter
the pen Jeff is just not able to keep
himself out
you know Jeff they can run 47 miles an
hour and it's got his mouth open yeah I
know Brad sick second stop don't
antagonize him
you're you're pushing him closer to me
right now when in Florida a man does
these things can I pet him
I promised you the most interesting stop
on your booktube this is by far yeah
Barry calls his home state the Ellis
Island for weird people yes we have a
lot of weirdness in this state
but is it fair to judge
21 million people because of the actions
of 19 million people
keep in mind
Dave Berry moved here 40 years ago
and never look back for all the crap
that Florida gets there are a lot of
people who they don't want to be
anywhere else also people keep moving
here I mean
I've never lived in a place that was a
you know criticized as the weirdest
stupidest place in the country the whole
country we get that all the time again
more people are moving here than any of
the other states and they're coming off
from from the states that keep
criticizing us so you know
go figure just I guess we're doing
everything we can to keep them out we're
raising the sea levels you know it's not
stopping them every like other day I
read a story like oh you're gonna have
jellyfish in your living room and you're
like 10 years yes yeah doesn't matter
they keep coming buying the you know
condos right on the water so
we talked about the serious Parts in the
story but the book is so much fun it
looks like I mean it really is so swamp
story vintage Dave Berry it is it is
vintage Dave Berry love him good stuff
Jeff good yeah a really good piece thank
you and the adventure too glad you have
all your fingers and toes yep and does
not surprise me at all that you went in
there by the way